[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler joaquim
pueyo maire ps des lances ont bon soir
monsieur puyoô merci d'être avec nous
ils d'amécourt avons côté porte parole
du mouvement de la ruralité bonsoir il
veut d'amécourt merci également à vous
d'être avec nous on va commenter un
petit peu un ce qu'on vient d'entendre
ce restaurateur voilà qui vit assez mal
cette mise en place du pass sanitaire
mais d'abord ce débat qui est relancé
sur le pass and i ter à la faveur d'
emmanuel macron qui voudraient bien
l'assouplir dans certains territoires
alors qu'on parle de le prolonger d'une
manière globale quelle est votre
position ils venaient mais cours passe
sanitaire en local ou coup l'arrêt final
pour vous
d'abord il faut noter la nouvelle
cacophonie du gouvernement avec un
ministre de la santé qui dit qu'on va
assouplir tout ça le ministre le premier
ministre qui donc dit qu'on va assouplir
le président qui revient derrière pour
expliquer au contraire qu'on va
prolonger et donc une fois de plus on
n'y comprend rien un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui annonce des
fermetures de classes dès qu'on a un cas
positif alors que le conseil
scientifique
préconise lui quand on a un cas positif
de tester la classe afin de savoir qui
est positif pour éviter de fermer des
classes et donc on est toujours dans
cette espèce de sentiment que il n'y a
pas véritablement de stratégie et qu'on
avance comme on dit chez nous au doigt
mouillé et jacques et aujourd'hui on a
ans on va on va de toute façon aller
plus en profondeur dans ce débat gens
qui me fuit ou justement sur ce
diagnostic
comme le dit yves d'amécourt on est dans
une certaine manière dans le en même
temps
compliqués et contradictoire à mettre en
oeuvre sur le terrain c'est dû en même
temps d' emmanuel macron
je ne sais pas mais on peut constater
quand même que le passé ni terre est
efficace il ya incité de nombreux
habitants qui au départ étaient
sceptiques se faire vacciner on a quand
même plus de 50 millions de français qui
ont été vaccinés donc c'est quand même
positif et moi je peut le remarquer cet
été on l'a maintenu toutes les grosses
manifestations sur la ville
avec des concerts je me souviens d'un
concert qu'à accueillir 1000 personnes
dans une jauge maximale de 1000
personnes et tout le monde avait le pass
anitea donc j'ai eu quand même suivi une
prise de conscience et le pass and i ter
à mon avis a été efficace là il est vrai
qu'actuellement la pandémie est en recul
selon les chiffres que nous avons on a
effectivement actuellement 1800
personnes qui sont hospitalisées
1800 réanimation dont il ya eu quand
même baisse nette sont des chiffres qui
sont incontestables il constate que 80%
de ceux qui sont hospitalisés
n'étaient pas vaccinés donc le pas
salutaire l'objectif c'est à la fois
d'assiter des français sont vaccinés et
puis moi je le constate quand même parce
que il ya eu ce témoignage des
restaurateurs mais moi je suis maire et
président communique urban ii soit 1000
habitants je vais souvent restaurant et
le week end et restaurants sont quand
même très relativement plein et il ya eu
une prise de conscience pas solidaires
quand même pose moins de problèmes qu'il
a posée lorsqu'on l'a mis en place au
départ alors actuellement effectivement
le taux d'acide ans diminue dans
certains départements je veux dans mon
département dans ma région on est à
moins de 50 pour cent mille habitants
donc effectivement on peut se poser la
question si il faudrait pas adapté le
pass and i ter en fonction des
territoires comme on l'avait fait lors
de la première vague lorsqu'on mettait
le compliment en fonction effectivement
des départements il y avait des
départements étaient vers d'autres qui
étaient ouverts foncé au rouge c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser et moi
j'écoute les médecins et les médecins
sont quand même très prudents ils nous
disent attention on n'a pas une unité
80% de la population et on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une nouvelle vague cet automne
moi j'avoue que la place du gouvernement
je serais plutôt prudent j'attendrai
d'une part les retombées de la rentrée
scolaire parce que la rentrée scolaire
elle a très peu de temps en quinze jours
donc on peut pas encore faire des
analyses attendons au moins quinze jours
battre en semaine pour faire une analyse
précise si effectivement la pandémie en
recul là la question de pyrite alizés le
passé ni terre peut se poser d'une
manière objective
de mes cours comme le dit à joaquim
pueyo d'une certaine manière ce
témoignage qu'on vient d'entendre ce
restaurateur d'une certaine façon c'est
un cas isolé pour vous vous l'avez
constaté sur le terrain les
restaurateurs il ya aucun problème ou
comme le disait monsieur chicheportiche
voilà c'est une contrainte économique et
ça pèse aussi sur ces commerçants qui
ont été déjà fragilisés
bah écoutez moi je suis dans une petite
commune de la gironde de 2900 habitants
et le nez de 0,2 les trois restaurants
delà de la commune aujourd'hui souffre
d'une baisse de fréquentation très
importante et ils vivent la même chose
que ce restaurateur c'est à dire qu'ils
sont obligés de dire à des gens de
quitter la salle de restauration parce
que ils n'ont pas le pass sanitaires je
remarque qu'aujourd'hui 21% des décès
hospitaliers ont chuté de 21% que les
les
86% des français éligibles aux vaccins
serre les plus de 12 ans ont eu leurs
premières vaccinations en fait je suis
assez d'accord avec monsieur le maire
d'alençon quand il dit que le pape
sanitaire a été utile pour encourager à
la vaccination parce qu'en fait le
gouvernement avait installé un tel doute
sur la vaccination que derrière il a été
obligé d'installer le pass sanitaires
pour inciter les gens à se faire
vacciner
j'aurais préféré qu'on encourage les
gens à se faire vacciner avec d'autres
types d'informations et on n'a pas eu
besoin du pass sanitaire en
responsabilisant les gens aujourd'hui
les courbes sont toutes décroissante il
ya trente-quatre départements qui sont
en dessous du seuil d'alert comme l'orne
et donc il faut absolument encourager
les gens et dire voilà on est en train
de réussir et donc il faut enlever le
pass sanitaire dans le plus d'endroits
possibles parce que sinon les français
ne comprendraient pas on leur promet de
mon miracles on leur annonce et tout le
monde le dit qu'on est sur la bonne voie
et on leur dit que après le 15 novembre
on va renouveler le passe à lithaire
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire à ce sujet
que le conseil constitutionnel quand il
avait été saisi par le parlement après
le vote du pass sanitaires avaient bien
signalé qu'il fallait que le pass anitea
il faudrait en sortir il fallait que les
mesures soient proportionnées avec le
risque or là le risque est en train de
décroître considérablement et si le
gouvernement prolonger le pass qualité
il va falloir qu'ils fassent des grandes
démonstrations pour expliquer pourquoi
il le prolonge effectivement j'imprime
puyoô c'est une question que beaucoup
dénoncent la question évidemment des
libertés publiques
vous en tant qu'élu quel est votre avis
là-dessus est ce que on est en train de
faire de l'abus de droit de pouvoir au
sein du gouvernement clairement je
voudrais faire une observation il ya eu
ce week-end des manifestations autour du
patrimoine qui ont connu un gros succès
moi je vois sur alençon les monuments
antiques visités et j'ai rencontré
beaucoup d'habitants et je pense que le
pastel terre lorsque vous assistez à une
pièce de théâtre un concert ou un match
de football ou pour visiter un monument
on voit que les gens sont détendus se
dire qu'il ya une détente une des temps
lui ils sont détendus niveau
psychologique c'est à dire qu'ils sont
assurés ça s'est il faut le il faut le
dire quand même bizarre et une passe
sanitaires et on voit effectivement dans
l'est dans les concerts et des
manifestations qui sont très positives
le deuxième point effectivement la
question que je me suis posée c'est par
rapport aux libertés individuelles est
ce qu'il ya une traçabilité et comment
cette traçabilité où on peut on peut on
te l'a repéré moi j'ai demandé à des
restaurateurs par exemple je passe avec
une passe sanitaire effectivement mon
nom est affiché ma date de naissance mon
anniversaire les mêmes et restaurateurs
qui m'a sauté mon anniversaire alors que
je ne connaissais pas du tout bon et on
m'a certifié que ces données effacées
mais c'est une question quand même qu'on
doit se poser parce qu'effectivement moi
je suis très attentif aux libertés
individuelles
le pass and iter doit effectivement être
deux cantonné bien encadré et il doit
être limité dans la durée et c'est
peut-être pour ça également comme vient
de me dire le président de la république
et d'ailleurs je voudrais lui dire que
j'étais maire rural pendant très
longtemps avant d'être maire d'alençon
est député et d'ailleurs je lui dis que
je comprends tout à fait le combat des
ruraux que je partage sur beaucoup de
domaines j'en profite pour lui dire ça
parce que je sais que c'est un
combattant pour défendre mon oral
le monde rural a besoin de combattants
tellement comme les territoires ruraux
et comme les villes moyennes une petite
parenthèse que je les lui faire alors si
effectivement on constate que dans
certains départements dans certaines
régions effectivement le le taux
d'incidence a vraiment diminué et bien
moi j'en il faudrait envisager
effectivement de suspendre le pass annie
terre peut-être pas immédiatement
attendons un petit peu le le retour de
la rentrée scolaire pour voir si
effectivement l'évolution se confiant au
niveau des jeunes et là effectivement
pourrait détendre se passer ni carte
dans les cas d'un département au taux
est faible voilà ça c'est mon point de
vue il ya dix ans vous pardonnez moi
j'ai une fille yves d'amécourt vous êtes
soutien de david lisnard chez les
républicains quelle doit être la
position pour vous de la droite sur la
question du pass sanitaires et notamment
lors de la prochaine présidentielle si
toutefois on y est encore parce qu'on
aimerait bien s'en sortir évidemment de
cette pandémie
j'espère qu'on en sera sorti mais
j'espère aussi que l'on on se servira de
de toute cette période que on
enregistrera un certain nombre de choses
et qu'on saura s'en servir la prochaine
fois que nous aurons une pandémie parce
que je j'entendais l'autre jour un
spécialiste des pandémies et il disait
c'est dommage que au moment de la
coronavirus on est pas ressorti les
textes qui avait été écrit au moment de
la grippe espagnole parce qu'en fait
tout ce que tout se passe exactement
qu'au moment de la grippe était
espagnole et si on tait s'était servie
de notre histoire si l'on est s'était
servie de notre expérience on aurait
peut-être fait des choses différemment
au moment de des premiers masques au
moment dé des premiers confinement etc
joaquim pueyo on entendait tout à
l'heure la nouveau je crois que c'était
il d'amécourt dire là on a incité à la
vaccination vous parliez de la rentrée
scolaire quand on voit ici ou là on a eu
ce témoignage ici même sur rt de deux
parents qui préfèrent
enlever leurs enfants de certaines
activités de leur passion du foot du
judo l'autre jour on a eu même un papa
qui a préféré que son fils sciences de
collège
alors qu'il voulait devenir handballeur
professionnel il pouvait pas servir dans
le collège actuel parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas céder au chantage un des
styles ans ce sont leurs mots
ça veut dire quoi qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire vous
écoutez moi je je respecte les décisions
des parents je pense que nous sommes
dans une société de liberté
indispensable pour faire des activités
sportives helmand pour assister à des
matchs ou pour aller à des concerts ou
pour fréquenter des lieux culturels ça
permet quand même de protéger de ceux
qui sont dans les enceintes alors quand
des parents ne souhaitent pas un jeu
j'en rencontre également je les écoute
je les respecte également dans la
décision mais ceci dit je le dis
franchement la vaccination a apporté
beaucoup pour cette pandémie on le voit
moi j'ai confiance à la science j'ai
confiance à la médecine et les médecins
que je rencontre sont pas tous d'accord
j'en conviens mais 99 % des médecins eux
souhaitent effectivement qu'un maximum
de français se fassent vacciner et
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas uniquement la
france regardez ce qui se passe en
italie on est imposée également le pass
annie terre pour aller dans les
entreprises par exemple bon en espagne
où maxime beaucoup également donc là ils
n'ont pas mis de passe à lutter
l'espagne incitent les personnes à les
faire vacciner moi je pense que le
vaccin c'est très important dans la
mesure où les vaccins sont quand même
efficace
on est en train de vacciner les
personnes âgées pour la troisième dose
pour effectivement davantage protégés et
moi j'espère que
l'efficacité des vaccins c'est comment
on y arrivait ce que voilà le passé ni
terre et on l'a souvent vu une
vaccination obligatoire qui dit pas son
nom c'est s'est tous fait débat je pense
je pense que effectivement si on atteint
80% de la population qui pour être
immunisé là on pourrait se passer
facilement du passé ni cas je pense
qu'on va l'atteindre rapidement
et puis sur les territoires notamment
les territoires ruraux où on voit bien
que le coc vie de s'estompe rapidement
on voit très bien là on pourrait
effectivement rapidement prendre une
décision pour suspendre pas sanitaire
qui est avec tablir si effectivement la
bonne la pandémie redémarre sportif est
bâti sur ce sujet là même si les
médecins vise attendait ne prenait pas
cette décision trop rapidement attendons
les analystes suite à la rentrée
scolaire qui doivent analystes important
et ce qui peut rassurer également les
familles voilà moi je fréquente bien sûr
les familles je vais visiter les écoles
les cantines scolaires
le protocole sanitaire est bien
respectée je pense que ça rassure à la
fois les enseignants comme les élèves
mais quand on aura fictivement les
analyses très fines on pourra se dire
bien voilà départements comme la manche
comme lors de la normandie en général on
pourrait effectivement
suspendre le pass annie terre et ça
permettrait effectivement à des
restaurateurs qui sont en difficulté de
rendre à l'achat de courage beaucoup de
petits miss hilton nicole le mot de la
fin pour vous bien que vous soyez en vue
réalité je vais vous parler du métro
mais tout de même la colère de ce
restaurateur elle n'est pas aussi
parfois fondées sur le fait qu'il ya des
incohérences on nous demande un passani
terre pour aller dîner au restaurant y
compris sur une terrasse mais le métro
bondé à paris on en a pas besoin est-ce
que s'il n'y a pas une partie de la
colère de certains justement on y passe
qui vient de là mais bien sûr le ça fait
partie des incohérences dont je parlais
tout à l'heure et qui ont émaillé le
débat sur le court au navire russe
depuis le début de la pandémie et donc
c'est tous ces problèmes de de
communication de discours
divergents qui font que les gens ont
perdu confiance si la confiance avait
été installé dès le démarrage je pense
qu'ils auraient eu moins de problèmes
pour pour convaincre les gens de se
faire vacciner je rappelle que la rn
messager a été
le découvreur de la rn messager a eu le
prix nobel je crois en 1965 donc c'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau et donc moi
aussi j'ai confiance dans la science et
derrière il faut il faut avancer mais
par contre il faut pas perdre de vue que
au fronton de nos mairies a écrit
liberté égalité fraternité
pendant cette pandémie je pense que la
liberté la fraternité doivent être deux
doigts devait être vraiment
respecté défendu et il faut aussi
respecter et défendre les maires et donc
monsieur le maire d'alençon et là vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de david
lisnard le maire de cannes qui est
d'ailleurs candidat à la présidence des
maires de france et donc les maires
doivent être respectées parce que ils
sont proches du terrain et ils peuvent
prendre des décisions que le premier
ministre depuis matignon ne peut pas
prendre merci en tout cas qu'elle est
vraiment mis en place des centres de
vaccination la déployé des moyens
considérables effectivement sur le
terrain bien on est attentif et séjours
merci de rappeler effectivement le rôle
des maires du territoire et vous savez
il ya beaucoup de maires peu importe et
sensibilités politiques on a fait le
même travail n'a partagé les mêmes
diagnostic et on a on les change
beaucoup et on a dépassé effectivement
les clivages politiques merci à tous les
deux joaquim pueyo et yves d'amécourt
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
française